this is pretty intimidating
[Music]
what is bread
bread is
texture it is love
bread is love bread is the
product of patience there's nothing
better more filling than super good
bread fresh out of the oven with a
slather of butter
i could eat that for dinner every night
everybody loves bread but also a lot of
people just take it for granted today
i'm here at bread lounge in los angeles
california and i'm gonna go through the
motions of an everyday baker for a
wholesale bakery it's not the easiest
job let's put it this way you have to be
up all night it's physical work you're
on your feet having spent the first
seven years of my career as a pastry
chef i kind of have a leg up on baking
but not at this scale i think even
people that were born to be bakers
didn't become bakers in one day
thankfully i'm small but mighty and at
the end of the day we'll see if they
would hire me or fire me
so the first step is weighing the
ingredients and putting them into the
mixer so now we're going to mix the
danish dough so we'll put everything in
the mixer
all that left is the yeast
that's cool
that's if you can hit it in the middle
without a dog catching it
today we have time but usually i just
pour like a third of it then it makes
come after a few minutes
yeah throw another third and taking the
dough out of the mixer that can be a
very challenging part and our danish
dough is almost ready
i just want to make sure there's no
pieces of butter showing up anywhere now
i remember my first days that i couldn't
even i didn't even know where to start
you get to a mixer with 2-300 pounds of
dough and someone tells you just take it
out you'll do the easy part take it out
of the mixer yes i'll do the
labor part of making a ball out of the
piece of dough
so there's different types of dough that
gives you different challenges the same
though are really
stiff and then it's just really heavy
it's hard to cut it and take it out of
the mixer some doughs are very sticky
and they stick all over your hands okay
so this is our jabata dough i use my
good hand to hold the scraper
and my weak hand to like a scoop to
scoop the dough so i just scooped the
dough and then i just cut it cut it
[Music]
how do you get it off of you when you
start cutting a lot of times in the
meantime it's sticking to your fingers
and then it doesn't want to come off it
doesn't want to come off and it doesn't
want to come off don't play with the
foot all right so i'm going to try and
do it with what
[Music]
how do you how many
like weeks days hours does it take for
an employee to get used to doing this
uh i think getting used to is one thing
doing it right is another thing
so you're telling me to keep my day job
hitting the mixer is not the recommended
way to take the dough out of the mixer
[Music]
that was on accident and if you don't
mind i'll take over before the sun rise
again
i for sure honestly
no joke thought the ciabatta pulling it
out of the bowl was gonna have me like
okay you're done quit hitting my bowl i
told you to stop get the hell out the
next step will be folding the dough
we're gonna do the same jabara dough
that we took out out of the mixer after
a few hours we need to fold it every few
hours so we stretch the dough put it in
the middle stretch put it in the middle
same thing from the sides and then we
just flip it so the seam is done here
we'll do one one
[Music]
i'm a very competitive person ron
so make it if okay if you're competitive
yes then this is not good okay it needs
to be smooth got it when you have lures
you're basically putting the dough the
wrong way so i like like that paper
should we want it outside it tastes most
customers don't like paper in their
japan so then here you would go and lay
it flat yeah and then you just have to
flip it down got it so you see how
smooth it is now see because i'm i did a
good job
much better
nice
beautiful
okay oh that was really good
you know what
i'm gonna have some coffee
i'll be back have fun you're doing a
great job thank you
no it's fun
this is why we do what we do i like
using my hands
and then usually the guy that does that
once he's done here we're going to help
them on the table so these guys are
cutting and then these guys are making a
round that's the pre-shape that's not
the shape of the loft yet we just
pre-shape it let it rest and then we'll
shape it
the better we do the pre-shape easier it
is to later on shape the bread it's a
matter of time we have to do this
process as fast as possible i'm going
fast
well the fastest one is in here so
there's a shot
the teamwork here is palpable like you
know that every single person here is
helping each other
it was really humbling to not be good at
something and have them be patient with
me
usually it's the same guy needs to shape
and put them on the tray
at the same time
[Music]
we can try for the bread on the linen
[Music]
and we fold the beginning so we make
like a little uh
tiny wall so the bread won't fall a
little bit of flour
put one
make a divider we don't want to put too
much flour
we cover
and it goes on the rack you have to be
fast you have to work in the same place
as the rest of the team
otherwise you get piles of dough piling
on the table and you're basically
putting the whole process behind them
can i say something yes see these guys
yeah they're waiting for you oh
they're not that much faster than me
now baking is a family thing right
most cultures it's a family generational
is your family
making bread no
i'm the only one in the family the first
one
i guess i'm the only crazy one
when you work in a bakery
your co-workers are like your family
yeah like you spend so much time
together you need each other's help it's
a teamwork so it really feels like a
family and usually people that work here
they're here for a long time so they
spend together really and they take care
of each other i hope so that's all you
hope for as a boss to be like okay every
the wheels are all moving in the right
direction because everyone respects
everyone it's like everyone has each
other's back it's exciting to be in that
environment because for me i get
creative juices flowing when i'm around
people that really care about what
they're doing okay so these are our
sourdough loft now it's time to bake
them so they're going to put them on the
loader score them then they go into the
oven for about an hour
i don't have very many days where i get
to be a student again and
the amount of work and patience that
bread entails is insane this one yeah
and this one
so claudette what what do you think is
the most fun part i think being on that
table is the most part yeah really yeah
because it's like more of a teamwork but
this part is interesting to me because
it's a guessing game like
you can't see it it's different from
when you're cooking and it's visually in
front of you so you see okay yeah this
is done this was fun for me because i
like feeling on things i don't know i
mean i know the basics and the
fundamentals of baking but i don't know
what you know because you've been doing
it for so long you know saying that i
can teach you something that i'm sure
about cooking with teach me a lot
a lot
you wouldn't even know where to start
okay claudette so we got a chance to
spend the whole day together in the
bakery and we
had the chance to go through the whole
process i got to see your
skills your abilities and i have to say
for a first time in a bakery you did
great and i would definitely hire you
well thank you
very welcome it's very very
refreshing to be in a bakery at this
size and what you guys are doing is
pretty amazing my one takeaway today is
that i just wish people
valued bread for the amount of pain in
me
work that it is
i think everything we don't have to work
hard for we take for granted if you have
the chance to go through a process of
how anything is made and you realize
that it's not made
just like that you might appreciate it
more but i think with bread today
things have changed and people have much
more appreciation to artisanal bread
where the bakers really take the time
and their effort to make the best bread
they can i wish people could see the
faces and the hands that touch bread in
places like this that still have magic
in handmade breads but it was very very
fun you have a very good team
thank you and you were a great addition
to the team today so you're welcome
anytime thank you so much
[Music]
you